Oh
[Music]
that's
relax relax wait what do you want to
happen here what what okay so top why
wait can you get up no so top you're
waiting for pain
go ahead
release the tension
Oh
at the elbow and maneuvers
[Music]
like this open open it then enclose it
you're afraid of getting the wrist
you're not gonna get it like that open
it it comes inside your arm then close
it don't make me think I'm doing DVD 10
con isn't moved when he's rushing at me
disease coming in so you can
reverse-engineer the technique if I'm
doing it even ten comp by prescription
he comes back in
I mean I don't know 10-time do you
understand but we want to work on this
technique I don't want to kick them in
the ribs so you understand okay go do
you understand there is a way to do the
technique that is how you do it if you
want to do your own stuff you do not
need to be here
got it well you walked in the door
so you obviously want to be here just
stop doing your own stuff you don't have
to go fast you understand
you just have to go right ahead so you
gotta care you're not carrying enough
I'll do it again I will take out
everything I go what you cannot do that
forget this stop you're just going to
open up and hold it in here you're gonna
do one open whole turkey in the shoulder
look two times off on side one open hole
to get the shoulder you have his wrist
pinched in your bicep elbow area open
look open then close not this
whoa open then closed and it goes to
your shoulder
boom open close open close to the
shoulder grab your key
okay close to your shoulder grab your D
that's your drill it's tearing them it's
not a technique Trump you understand it
security drill practice your carrier go
yeah now price is the same just extend
your arm wait don't do anything did his
arm fall
easy you keep trying to stop this
football his heart did not fall you see
that he's not gonna swing you over then
pinch the bicep that's it yeah
trust but then close one just trust
trust you see who cares
he's doing goofy stuff aren't you do you
look like you're simply a kit you can't
no very tight relax easy on the pole
bring your body over
good okay go don't let a tribute you're
not gonna learn is the person who's
teaching it doesn't you understand and
when someone gives a crap comes into
contact and someone who looks like
they're not giving a crap or doesn't
know how to give the crap it's gonna
feel like this to you you get it so
every time it feels like that you have
to stop clashing okay let go and just do
what you're being told to do if you
think your version is better
we'll talk after class and you can show
me your version and we'll discuss the
kink and easy illogical merits and the
tactical merits I will find her that got
it
but in class you will practice getting
out of your own way that's the true art
getting out of your own way it's not
hard
it just feels hard it's not a big deal
to stop doing what you're doing and do
what you're being shown to do if it's
hard and you keep having it be difficult
you just need to seriously look at
yourself
because you're going to start expecting
life to accommodate that and it's not
going to it's a downward spiral into
victim mentality do you understand
so here practice getting out of your own
way it didn't cost you anything
and you gain everything got it